dude gunman broke into her home and shot
her 12 times
[Music]
there was a woman who has recently just
hunted down 10 Mexican cartel members
that kidnapped her daughter
how did she find them is she like Emily
Blunt and uh sicario like that nah she's
like Denzel Washington Emily Blunt got
used in sicario remember yeah she's like
Angelina Jolie with Tomb Raider oh
that's Tomb Raider right there dude
that's Tomb Raider right there I mean
tomb Raiders bitten a lot it's been a
while isn't that the lady that killed
Selena
that's her manager wow
yeah so um she doesn't look like she
could hunt nobody that's the Abuelita
Avenger yeah
that's black widow dude so her daughter
was kidney
[Laughter]
yeah uh basically her name is Miriam
Rodriguez uh she was horrified and
heartbroken when uh authorities were
basically not able to do anything for
when her daughter Karen was abducted so
she was like I gotta do [__] myself she
eventually started an investigation that
got her enough information to point
fingers at members of One of Mexico's
most dangerous drug cartels the Los
Zetas Jesus after narrowing down one of
the men who was involved in her
daughter's kidnapping she started an
investigation off of that so I you know
I'm I'm just imagining the [__] red
yarn that's [__] dude I've always said
this though man like moms and girls that
are suspecting that their boyfriend's
cheating make the best detectives moms
with missing children Joe's always said
this yes of it we have multiple videos
and if they had that
if but worked for the police department
yeah you know it's not activated unless
they love them that's why does she live
in like one of the bordering states
where it's pretty much ruled by the
cartel uh it doesn't specifically talk
about where she like Tijuana's um yeah
like or El Paso Texas or like there's a
bunch of states that are just oh she's
on the American side no no no she's in
Mexico oh yeah she's on the Mexico side
um she actually she was like walrus yeah
Juarez you're so excited yeah keep
naming City so I don't talk about this
um she wanted to get answers
she wasn't really looking for blood or
anything like that she just wanted to
get some answers she disguised herself
as a health care worker and led on that
she was conducting a local survey in the
area
eventually she gathered enough
information for police to arrest the man
she suspected was involved in her
daughter's kidnapping oh the police
actually did their job with the help of
her son Luis Miriam managed to get this
gang member Behind Bars and once he was
he was more than willing to give up the
names of other gang members wow too
one of the members named was just 18
years old a detail that Miriam used to
her Advantage relying on her motherly
compassion to convince him to give up
her daughter's location
damn guilt-trip them unfortunately this
led to her devastating discovery that
Karen had been killed oh but at least
she found her that I mean she found her
dude what a gangster this one but this
fueled Miriam's mission to take down the
notorious gang members that were
responsible so uh it ended up leading to
a mass excavation of more dead bodies in
that area than she found her daughter is
almost she's the real-life John Wick for
real yeah but then like when you have a
society where crime just pays man it
pays so good
like in spoken like a true criminal it's
like but the options it's like so in
America we have options we could work
for Google and like we could be like you
know you ever see those Tick Tock videos
working at Goods working at [__] meta
Mexican drug cartoons yeah it's like
working out better
in Mexico they don't got no [__] Tick
Tock videos of that [__] of like you
know going to [__] meta today like no
they got cartel videos like going to
cartel life stuff and then they're like
living large they're living good there's
no JK news in Mexico dude winter
cocktail lifestyle yeah it's so big
there is a chicken Noodle's here yeah
then that's hot then that's that's
that's beautiful but probably not yeah
it stands for Jalisco cartel but I
thought when the cartel pays better than
all the other options that you have
that's what makes it [__] like
dangerous yeah if you don't got options
it's true yeah yeah but gen Z will tell
you it's not about the money guys
they're passionate they're passionate
about kidnapping you know it's like ever
since I was a kid I wanted to be a
kidnapper
Miriam dedicated the next few years of
her life hunting now members of The
Notorious gang responsible for her
daughter's murder over the next three
years she adopted lots of different
disguises changing up her hair
impersonating election officials getting
close to unsuspecting family oh that's
smart damn she's that old she could
learn every last detail about the people
responsible for her daughter's abduction
and death holy see that's the way to do
it it's the Long Way well she used her
her looks to her Advantage instead of
just yeah yeah she wasn't gonna start
shooting people right that's true
because if she was fine as [__] her
cover would have been so blown yeah yeah
how come too much attention dude right
now she just looks
too much I think you're blend in man
yeah we got to delete this video we're
outing her dude we gotta throw this one
up well she already thought about the
all the all the dudes yeah within the
three years Marion was responsible for
taking down 10 different gang members
who had tried to make a run for it and
start new lives oh wow whoa she goes but
in 2017
Miriam's life came to a tragically
abrupt end when she was shot dead in her
home oh why you gotta do that to me man
by what why'd you do that to him man was
it one of those [__] up Anthony was it
one of the cartel guys moms
you put my son in jail yeah yeah yeah
it's a never-ending vicious cycle dude
moms bro she became an assassin yeah
this is gonna be a movie bro yeah The
Grieving mom was killed on May 10th
Mother's Day in Mexico
plan that [__] dude gunman broke into
her home and shot her 12 times they
planned it dude although Miriam had
requested arm protection in the years
after her cartel takedown she once said
as reported by uh times I don't care if
they kill me I died the day they killed
my daughter well yeah damn man that gave
me chills bro but on Mother's Day she
died and she went to see her daughter
that's true that is the sweet ending
yeah that's so funny damn uh this is so
sad because I want to end this I'm going
to take out the people who hurt my
daughter and they can do whatever they
want to me Miriam's son Luis continues
his mom's mission helping to find cartel
members responsible for the abduction
and murder of family oh my God Fernando
a missing person's ass this is like the
Mexican Batman so at what point do you
have to like come to peace with it and
move on with your life oh no because
then it's just gonna be a constant cycle
of people killing people
but on the good guy side they weren't
killing anybody they're just taking them
in prison getting evidence yeah they're
doing it the right way getting Justice
yeah but also if you pull the yarn
enough and you get high enough then
you're gone because you're not the
professional like you're not like a
police officer that's true yeah yeah you
can only go so far yeah they'll find
also endanger other people too by being
a neighborhood watch Person yeah I just
said it's kind of cool though that she
achieved what she wanted before she died
that's pretty cool though yeah but then
it's a threat to the cartel because if
people see that she like empowered
herself to fight against the cartel
she's like a hero then they needed like
like a normal civilian just infiltrating
their system and she was able to do it
so they're like now I gotta teach the
community a lesson not to do this
I mean if I was for sun now Mexican
Batman that's what I'm saying yeah I'd
be a little bit nervous because you know
you're probably also on that hit list
you know what I'm saying I wonder what
why they killed her daughter in the
first place
like was it like a random thing they
probably just snatched her up damn
that's something they say she was
abducted who knows and then if
especially if they're you know they
ended up finding and Excavating that
area and finding like other like bodies
and stuff who knows that it's just the
sign of because I know that like at
least uh not the new generation cartel
people but the
um the veteran ones do have kind of like
a code of conduct where they don't do
random dumb [__] because it just creates
problems
maybe this is like some new gen stuff
because this is a because I'm sure
there's
would you say the name of the cartel was
Los Zetas are they like is that like El
Chapo's guys
is that the same dudes Zeta is like Z
right so like the Z's I thought I didn't
know those that those are the ones that
have like the Mexican Navy SEAL guys oh
that's crazy I think you're right I
think they were trained by the U.S
Special Forces and then they used to be
the drug busters that's and the debut
were like they're like dude there's more
money in this Gary
that yeah I don't know how you stopped
that there's a um this is a Mexican
criminal Syndicate Formerly Known uh one
of the most dangerous Mexican drugs uh
drug cartels they're known for engaging
in brutally violent shock and all
tactics such as beheadings torture and
indiscriminate murder while primarily
concerned with drug trafficking the
organization also runs profitable sex
and gun rackets but see that's what I'm
saying if the when the car tells
anything else yeah everybody dude like
like one documentary about this uh
Village in Mexico that kicked out the
cartel the bat Vigilantes right and then
they're just like man we're taking our
community back and then the community
leaders became the cartels themselves
they just started selling drugs
themselves but just not in their
Community but then it's like how do you
if it just keeps this cycle it just
keeps happening and no one could like
there's like no goodness or whatever you
call it like and because the cartels
still it doesn't the cartel is solving
an issue of like a bad economy basically
you can't you don't have any jobs you
don't have anything going on so then
everyone the cartel just keeps staying
in power
[Music]
foreign